à chaque fois que je vois une marque ou
un produit je peux pas m'empêcher de
m'imaginer les gens qui ont bossé dessus
derrière en réunion parce que parfois
ils prennent des décisions bizarres ces
gens là alors alors je m'imagine les
réunions chez ikea chez ap
mon cerveau ça donne ça les réunions
chez apple a l'iphone avec plus de
pixels
voilà j'ai fait ça m'aide à trouver note
de steve jobs avec des idées de nouveaux
produits
bon j'ai pas ouais non c'est pas prêt du
tout l'iphone 6 iphone chez microsoft
combien ne surpasse on a vendu ça c'est
très bien qu'on en parle comme ça on
peut aller chez nokia vous vous souvenez
du 33 10
bah oui c'est le téléphone qui se
vendait chez nintendo ou allemagne je
pense est un tout nouveau jeu avec un
nouveau personnage est ou non je déconne
un nouveau maillot ouais chez microsoft
bing ça marche bien cette opération
non mais je vous entends les mecs chez
nintendo on la connaît mal au point de
croix chez des huit pour des raisons de
compréhension on change le nom de la
chaîne des vite devient touche pas à mon
poste cuvée à la baisse est plus clair
ça passe bien par m6 il nous faut une
émission de cuisine top chef c'est bien
ça et aussi un programme court d'humour
vers 20 heures c'est nos ménages
scènes de ménage chez tf1 il est par une
émission de cuisine top chef
ok enfin masterchef un programme
d'humour à 20h au kenya voisin il y a un
truc sur le champagne chez d'activision
nom call of duty on n'a qu'à ajouter 10
y est chantal chez deezer est en retard
ah ouais il est déjà 10 heures oui chez
haribo mais que c'est bon j'ai lancé la
prod de 20 tonnes de réglisse sinon
personne n'est blanc on va devoir
remettre un petit peu dans chaque boîte
avec personne va les manger du coup et
c'est pas si mauvais chez google +
[Musique]
chaîne youtube
et voici la liste des youtube en
français ok donc cette partie va sur
canal plus et sept parties continuent à
faire des vidéos dans sa chance sur la
table
ok au boulot chez google + mais je sais
chez youtube
les mecs je sais à partir d'aujourd'hui
tous les comptes youtube deviennent des
comptes google+ c'est mon idée tu as
aimé y être le mec d'ensemble est
vachement ok bah ouais ouais très long
mais ouf ça on le dit souvent
voilà j'avais cousins chez ikea f
voilà notre prochaine table basse va
s'appeler d'une petite que feu ça sonne
bien non parce que le basque feu s'était
déjà nos petits tabourets en rotin sinon
mais dévoyée la ta gueule chez avast la
base virale b ps a été mis à plat les
parties tout seul
certes ça marche bien des marchés
arrivent sa part on valide à votre
prénom c'est un bagel chez red bull
et chez kamel
chez bic et ça se vend toujours ouais
bon boulot à la vue à la ratp
atx et absolut vodka et chaleur chez nrj
12 les anges de la télé réalité à melun
je fais alors je sais où sont jamais
allés
les anges et elle a été à l'école ou
chez twitter
bon voilà les noms commencent à acheter
que ces partis hier trt j'aime chez
facebook me suis fait cliché twitter ok
ne paniquons pas on va trouver une
solution
j'aime j'aime verte et chez nespresso
nouvelles couleurs de capsule rose
pivoine et le café amassé même jefri un
abonnement tout illimité 20 euros par
mois sans engagement
chez orange la chefferie et si on est
abonné chez prix le prix tombe à 16
euros chez sévère chez prime pour chaque
abonnement donne de l'argent et le
fameux didier ah oui bon d'accord c'est
un petit peu bizarre dans mon cerveau
c'est vrai mais je suis pas le seul toi
aussi tu t'imagines des réunions
rappelons que moi ça lâche un
commentaire
[Musique]
on chérit voici le prix tombe à 16 euros
oh oui je m'y attendais pas et les bons